Mr Speaker one of the prime minister's
own MPS says Britain is facing a
mortgage catastrophe
does he agree with her
Mr Speaker can I start by joining The
Honorable gentleman in his uh tribute to
Glenda Jackson uh and Mr Speaker it's
also right that we do support those with
the mortgages and this is why the
absolute right economic priority is to
halve inflation because inflation is
what is driving interest rates up
inflation is what erodes people savings
and pushes up prices and ultimately
makes them poorer now this is why a long
time before I had this job I highlighted
the importance of tackling inflation
it's why that I said it is never easy to
root out inflation but we will take the
difficult and responsible decisions to
do so it's an approach that the IMF has
its strongly endorsed in their words and
describing our actions as decisive and
responsible
Mr Speaker I realized the promise to
spent all week saying he doesn't want to
influence anyone or anything
keeping to that with his answer he he
knows very well the cause of the
mortgage catastrophe 13 years of
economic failure and a Tory kamikaze
budget which crashed the economy and put
mortgages through the roof
so will the Prime Minister tell us how
much the Tory mortgage penalty is going
to cost the average homeowner
well Mr Mr Speaker Mr Speaker as ever
The Honorable gentleman isn't aware of
the global macroeconomic situation but
positively
substantively
but substantively what I what let me
tell him and the house what we are doing
to support those with mortgages we have
deliberately and proactively increased
the generosity of our support for the
mortgage interest scheme we've also
established a new SCA Community which
will protect people with mortgages for
example moving them on to interest-only
mortgages or lengthening mortgage terms
and we have spent tens of billions of
pounds supporting people with the cost
of living particularly the most
vulnerable but that is the difference
between us Mr Speaker while he is always
focused on the politics we are actually
just getting on and doing the job
let's test that because the question he
refuses to answer he actually knows the
answer this question is 2 900 pounds
extra that's the cost to the average
family of the Tory mortgage penalty now
he was warned by experts about this as
long ago as Autumn last year but it
either didn't get it didn't believe of
it or didn't care because he certainly
didn't do anything and when I raised
this a couple of months ago he had the
goal to stand at that dispatch box and
say he was delivering for homeowners
how is an extra 2 900 pounds a year of
repayment delivering for homeowners
[Applause]
that's right he talks about interest
rates perhaps all gentleman could
explain why interest rates are at
similar levels in the United States in
Canada in Australia and New Zealand why
they're at the highest level in Europe
that they've been for two decades Mr
Speaker that's why it's important that
we have a plan to reduce inflation but
in contrast what do we hear from one
more gentlemen he wants to borrow an
extra 28 billion pounds a year that
would make the situation worse he wants
to ban new supplies of energy from the
naughty that would make the situation
worse and and he wants to give in to
Union's unaffordable pay demands that
would make the situation worse Mr
Speaker he doesn't have many policies
but the few that he does have all have
the same thing in common they're
dangerous inflationary and working
people would pay the price
foreign
interest in the mortgage Market in
California but I'm talking about movie
told us here
and whilst his government is consumed in
law in law breaking chaos and Division
working people are paying the price
this morning I spoke to James in Selby
he's a police officer working hard to
keep people safe every day the Tory
mortgage penalty is going to cost him
and his family 400 pounds more each and
every month that's nearly 5 000 pounds
he told me this morning they may not
want to hear this he told me this
morning
that they've decided to sell their house
to downsize and he's just told his
children they're going to have to start
sharing bedrooms
why should James and his family pay the
cost of the prime minister's failure
well Mr Mr Speaker I hope when The
Honorable gentleman was talking to James
he explained that his economic policies
would make James's situation worse Mr
s that's me saying that Mr Speaker the
independent the independent Institute of
fiscal study says his policy of
never-ending debt and borrowing would
damage change because it would increase
inflation and drive up interest rates
leaving James and everybody else in this
country horror Mr Speaker the IMF has
said that our plan prioritizes not what
is politically easy but what is right
for the British people that is what
responsible economic leadership looks
like Mr Speaker
James and his family will have been
listening to that prime minister
that light
a few years 7.5 million people are going
to be in the same boat
all paglatory mortgage penalty months
after month after month
the situation is so dire that
repossessions are already up 50 percent
a total betrayal of the idea that if you
work hard you'll get on
so what's the Prime Minister going to do
to make sure more families don't lose
their homes
Mr Speaker I know he's reading from his
prepared script but he failed to
actually listen to the answer that I
gave well I did it I did actually spell
out in detail what we are doing Mr
Speaker we've increased the generosity
of support for mortgage interest scheme
we did that proactively in advance we've
also established a new FCA consumer Duty
that will protect borrowers for example
by allowing them to extend their
mortgage terms or switch to
interest-only mortgages and we have
spent tens of billions of pounds
supporting households with living costs
those are the practical steps that we
are taking to help James and other
families who are facing these situations
but what I would say because he
mentioned mortgage arrears and uh
repossessions I am pleased to say Mr
Speaker they are actually running at a
level today that is below when we enter
the pandemic Mr Speaker because of the
actions that we're taking but more
importantly than that perhaps Mr Speaker
is that they are also running three
times lower than the level We inherited
from the last Labor government
[Applause]
Mr Speaker Mr Speaker I'm sure from the
vantage point of his helicopter
everything might look fine but that's
not the lived experience of those on the
ground after 13 years of economic
failure across the country people are
paying the price of uncosted Reckless
damaging Decisions by the Tory party and
even now as mortgages go through the
roof the prime minister is planning to
wave through honors and peerages for
those who cause misery for Millions is
what does it say about this government
that while working people are worrying
about mortgage like paying the bills
even repositions the Tory party is
rewarding those guilty of economic
vandalism
Mr Speaker no amount of personal attacks
and Petty Point scoring can describe
Mr Speaker he comes here every week to
make the same Petty points we are
getting on and delivering for this
country yes Mr Speaker
the challenge
that's why we are on track to
fixing it we are reducing waiting list
we are stopping the boats all while he
is focused on the past focused on the
politics it's all taught whereas from
this government and from this prime
minister we deliver for the country
[Music]
[Applause]